on va parler de la réforme des retraites
avec Alex le Breton va pas vous demander
votre avis de la Bretagne on parle de la
réforme des retraites à 16h sera donné
le coup d'envoi des débats au Parlement
sur cette réforme Elizabeth Band a fait
un pas hier en direction des
républicains qui n'ont pas franchement
tous ces îles à main tendues
mathiasarayez coup d'envoi d'un débat de
50 jours au Parlement dans une interview
au Journal du Dimanche Elisabeth borne a
déclaré qu'elle espérait pouvoir compter
sur le soutien des républicains dans le
dossier des retraites depuis des années
il défendent une réforme des retraites
reposant sur un décalage progressif de
l'âge de départ à 64 ans et une
accélération de la réforme Touraine
Valérie Pécresse prenait même 65 ans je
suis convaincu que le groupe LR sera
cohérent avec ce qu'il a toujours porté
si elle annonce avoir fait des
concessions la copie de la première
ministre n'est pas encore satisfaisante
pour le président des Hauts de France
Xavier Bertrand est-ce qu'il est trop
complaisant avec le gouvernement je
pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
ferme et engager un bras de fer parce
qu'il n'y a que qui peuvent amener cette
réforme à devenir alors généralement
plus acceptable
vice-président exécutif DLR Aurélien
Pradier
ma position n'a pas varié je souhaite
que ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans ne soit pas les dindons de
la farce si notre amendement n'est pas
repris à la virgule près je m'opposerai
à cette réforme
cette position le patron du parti Eric
sutile à regrette notre famille
politique n'est pas une caserne je
respecte toutes les positions de mes
collègues mais pour moi la cohérence
avec ce que nous avons toujours défendu
doit nous amener à faire des choix
courageux conforme à l'intérêt supérieur
du pays dans l'opposition la bataille
des amendements est lancée plus de 20
000 ont déjà été déposés dont 18 000 par
la nuque et on va parler du débat
parlementaire dans quelques instants
mais d'abord sur la position prise hier
par Elisabeth borne elle a tenté de
faire un pas en direction des
républicains bon on va vivre c'est pas
franchement concurrent
non c'est pas oui mais on est dans une
si vous voulez là il faut monter les
enchères les républicains et ils savent
plus du tout ils habitent à mon avis ils
vont se prendre une raclée mais
monumentale et c'est tout ce qui a
souhaité d'ailleurs si jamais à des
élections à venir parce que c'est
vraiment incompréhensible enfin ils sont
mais ils sont ridicules au sens propre
du terme ils sont absolument ridicules
pendant des années des années ils ont
demandé à ce qu'on recule l'âge de
départ à la retraite l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite pendant des années
des années ils ont comment critiquer
tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédés qui n'étaient pas de leur
sensibilité pour dire que c'était des
mots et qui ne faisait rien et là
aujourd'hui il nous joue une partition
qui est incompréhensible qui est
incompréhensible pour un électorat me
semble-t-il de droite alors je veux bien
qu'on peut être de droite et sociale
bien sûr mais pas social comme ça c'est
évidemment pas ce que demande la raison
parce que en plus ils sont ils sont au
contraire à toute la raison c'est
mathématique cette réforme cette réforme
alors évidemment vous pouvez très bien
et d'ailleurs Claude baluré l'a très
bien expliqué tout à l'heure c'est sûr
que le système para répartition on veut
le préserver tous les Français veulent
le préserver à terme à mon avis il sera
condamné parce qu'il y aura pas assez
d'actifs pour payer les retraites de
tous les retraités donc il va falloir
changer un peu notre système mais en
attendant si on veut le conserver il
faut faire une réforme qui soit une
réforme qui consiste à faire que les
Français travaillent plus et que et bien
on avec des aménagements de toute
manière parce que toutes les le système
actuel est injuste donc qu'on a qu'on
vienne pas nous dire que le système à
venir sera encore plus injuste
l'injustice principale c'est entre le
secteur public les secteurs privés ou
c'est
aucun pays ne supporterait ça nous on
l'accepte alors maintenant on vient
rassuiner pour nous dire mais attendez
les femmes ont peut-être travaillé trois
mois de plus mais évidemment que c'est
regrettable mais vous ne pouvez pas
avoir sur le papier un système qui soit
absolument
d'une justice irréprochable alors il
faut évidemment avoir des dispositions
particulières ça je suis d'accord pour
les carrières longues et pour la
pénibilité ça paraît d'une grande d'une
grande pertinence évidemment mais la
pénibilité c'est plus la pénibilité du
début ou du milieu du 20e siècle quand
on est à la tête d'un train et bien je
crois pas qu'on travaille de la même
façon que quand on était à la tête d'un
train dans les années dans les années 50
donc il y a c'est tout ce débat est un
débat qui manque singulièrement de
raison et c'est un débat qui fait rire
mais pousser de rire tous les étrangers
récemment j'ai fait une correspondance
pour une télévision belge ou en face de
moi j'avais trois interlocuteurs qui
étaient priés en quatre il me dit mais
attendez mais nous c'est 67 ans la
retraite vous êtes ridicule vous avez
raison bon on se partage les coups avec
Yves il a tapé sur les républicains moi
j'ai tapé sur le gouvernement je
comprends pas leur stratégie il faut
voir que la principale bien sûr mais il
faut voir que la principale concession
elle a déjà été faite 65 à 64 ans elle
avait pour but quoi d'acheter le groupe
LR en espérant que LR vote la réforme on
sait aujourd'hui que ça n'a pas marché
pas parce que LR n'est en effet pas sur
la bonne ligne etc il s'agit pas
d'acheter mais parce que pour des
raisons politiques ce groupe déjà est en
grande partie des structuré c'est un
groupe de survivants tes dernières
élections et c'est un groupe dont on a
vu que et bien ces chefs n'ont pas
réellement d'autorité sur l'ensemble de
ce groupe extrêmement disparate donc là
on fait de nouvelles concessions ces
nouvelles concessions elles vont pas
rendre plus cohérente le vote de LR il
va falloir à chaque moment durant les 20
jours que il y est à l'Assemblée
nationale une majorité sur tous les
articles sur tous les amendements etc ce
sera pas le cas LR et le groupe qui est
le moins présent en séance et là ça va
probablement être sauve sauver moi je
vais dans ma circonscription pour
expliquer que je suis pas vraiment pour
cette réforme et de toute façon je serai
pas dans l'étape des votes de l'autre
côté il va en être de même pour la
majorité parce que c'est bien beau de
dire on va dissoudre mais du coup les
députés de la majorité les plus naïfs et
les plus convaincus ça peut arriver
alors que l'exécutif n'en a absolument
aucune intention parce que aucun intérêt
et bien vont se réfugier également en
circo pour expliquer que ils sont sur le
terrain et que cette réforme il approuve
pas tout à fait donc là on va avoir des
amendements adopté de 6 dollars et le
fait que LR soutienne ou pas ne changera
absolument rien à ça parce qu'encore une
fois dit là avec Hélène ne sert à rien
vous pouvez ensuite faire des
concessions sur la pénibilité mais ça
aussi le gouvernement ayant utilisé un
PLFSS ce sont des cavaliers sociaux donc
ce sera reporté un autre texte ça ne
permettra ni d'apaiser les syndicats ni
d'avoir des parlementaires de votre côté
donc là à ce stade là je vois mal
comment il revien sans doute comment
est-ce qu'on évite le 49 alinéa 3
cherchez encore un deal avec erikiotti
va savoir une bataille de retard une
bataille qui est déjà perdue et pour le
gouvernement bah c'est montrer que en
matière de procédure parlementaire sur
cette réforme en tout cas ils ont quand
même raté ouais on va y venir tout de
suite parce que
c'est très cadré très serré les députés
ont entre aujourd'hui à 16h et le
vendredi 17 février à minuit pour
examiner ce projet loi de réforme des
retraites qui est un budget de la
Sécurité sociale rectificatif et c'est
là où est toute la nuance puisque le
temps d'examen est limité à 11 jours pas
plus c'est ce que préconise est-ce que
prévoit la Constitution alors dès cet
après-midi et bien la pression va monter
d'entrée avec d'abord le discours de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne pour
défendre cette réforme ainsi que les
discours des ministres concernés par le
texte et puis les députés vont ensuite
examiner une motion de rejet pure et
simple de ce texte déposer par
l'opposition et si cette réforme des
retraites n'est pas rejetée place à
l'examen d'une émotion référendaire qui
si elle est votée par une majorité de
députés et bien suspend le débat et
demande au Président de la République
l'organisation d'un référendum sur cette
réforme des retraites alors à la fois la
gauche et notamment les communistes et
le rassemblement national ont déposé
chacun leur motion référendaire mais la
gauche refuse de voter la motion du
rassemblement national qui devrait être
discutée cette cet après-midi et pour le
patron du RN Jordan Bardella et bien ce
n'est pas du tout cohérent on va
l'écouter je mets au défi tous les
partis qui se disent d'opposition de
voter cette motion référendaire ce qui
ne voteront pas cette motion ne pourront
plus se dire d'opposition voilà Jordan
mardella qui met la pression sur la
gauche et sur les républicains pour
voter cette motion référendaire du
rassemble national qui va être débattue
et si cette notion est rejetée et bien
place au débat sur la réforme entre les
députés et puis à l'examen des
amendements pour modifier améliorer
cette réforme des retraites et puis
aussi pour ralentir les débats puisque
au total 20 000 amendements ont été
déposés sur ce texte dont 18000 de la
part de la gauche de la part de la nupes
ce qui a de quoi agacé la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a El brune
Pivet avec 20000 amendements j'ai fait
mes petits calculs aussi 20 000
amendements on dit 5 minutes par
amendement ce qui est pas énorme c'est
40 semaines de débats c'est plus d'une
année du travail parlementaire qui ne
serait que ça qui ne parlerait plus de
justice qui ne parlerait plus de de la
loi de programmation militaire qui
parlerait plus du pouvoir d'achat des
Français et donc les députés n'auront
pas le temps d'aller au bout de l'examen
de ce budget de la Sécurité sociale
rectificatif et comme le veut l'article
47 Alina 1 de la Constitution à la fin
des 11 jours d'examen donc le vendredi
17 février à minuit et bien le texte ira
directement au Sénat qui aura lui
jusqu'à la date du 4 mars pour en
débattre député et sénateurs le 4 mars
devront alors se mettre d'accord sur une
version commune du texte lors d'une
réunion qu'on appelle la commission
mixte paritaire en cas de désaccord
entre les deux chambres et bien le
dernier mot sur le texte reviendra à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés qui
auront alors jusqu'au 26 mars pour
rediscuter cette réforme des retraites
et si ils n'ont toujours pas car il y a
trop d'amendements et bien le
gouvernement aura le pouvoir de faire
passer par voie d'ordonnance cette
réforme c'est à dire en se passant du
Parlement et puis si jamais il y a peu
d'amendements pour ce dernier mot et que
les députés ont le temps d'aller au bout
de l'examen du texte mais que le
gouvernement n'a pas la majorité
suffisante pour adopter cette réforme
des retraites et bien Elizabeth borne
pourra utiliser l'article 49 alias 3 de
la Constitution pour passer en force
faire passer ce texte sans tenir compte
du vote des députés comme cela est
possible avec tous les textes
budgétaires merci Alex cette réforme de
retraite finalement c'est l'impossible
débat parlementaire Benjamin très très
compliqué la gauche utilise une
stratégie qui édite du mur d'amendement
qui puisse comprendre c'est à dire qu'on
voulait retrouver dans toutes les
grandes réformes sociales il s'agit de
paralyser le Parlement pour permettre à
la mayonnaise de monter dans la rue et
de tenter de pousser le gouvernement à
49 alinéa 3 fondamentalement impopulaire
alors après ce que 20 000 amendements
étaient nécessaires peut-être pas
peut-être que la gauche aurait pu
laisser courir le débat jusqu'au fameux
article 7 parce que là ils vont manquer
justement cette tribune cette question
de l'âge mais la réalité c'est que il
est évident que dès le moment où vous
lancez cette bataille il s'agit de ne
pas voter le texte au bout du compte
alors le gouvernement n'est pas obligé
de rentrer dans ce cas des 50 jours 20
jours etc il peut laisser un peu de
l'Est il peut faire comme s'il n'avait
pas utilisé un PLFSS 47-1 ça entraîne
pas d'un consumérité du texte mais
évidemment avec 20 000 amendements c'est
comme le disait il y a la grande pivée
vous ne pouvez pas arriver au bout du
texte quoi qu'il arrive au-delà du 17
février il peut aller théoriquement il y
a déjà des précédents alors sur les
budgets mais il faut voir que les
articles sont plus ou moins copiés
collés entre les budgets et les PLFSS
théoriquement il y a pas de juris il y a
une jurisprudence qui lui permet d'aller
au-delà après il y a deux problèmes pour
lequel à mon avis il va être contre il y
a trois problèmes pour lesquels il va
être contraints d'utiliser le 49
alinatoires dès la première lecture
d'abord il y a quelques semaines dans le
Canard Enchaîné vous avez l'eau en famus
qui envoie un Scud il dit grosso modo je
vins des bas parlementaires où il
devrait y avoir un vote s'il doit y
avoir un vote avec 20000 amendements
soit vous arrivez au bout des 20 000
amendements et on y est encore en 2024
soit d'utiliser le 49 alinéa 3 le
deuxième élément c'est que on évoquait
tout à l'heure c'est majorité de briquet
de brocs si vous avez 10 députés en
séance lors des prochaines semaines il
faut que la majorité en ait toujours 6
qui vote contre les amendements de
l'opposition ça arrivera pas parce que
vous allez avoir beaucoup de députés de
la majorité qui soit auront des
scrupules voteront parfois entre le
modèle le RN la Nupe sur des amendements
qui va faire que le texte va
profondément probablement être de nature
et la seule façon pour le gouvernement
et bien de s'abrer ses amendements dont
il ne veut pas c'est le 49 alinéa 3 le
troisième élément là aussi on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est que je vois pas de
majorité infinés se dessiner sur le
texte et si jamais le gouvernement n'est
pas sûr de sa majorité et qu'il risque
un rejet qui soit prévu ou qu'il soit
surprise ben là même si le dispositif
est impopulaire mieux vaut ça plutôt
qu'un rejet qui annulerait toute la
procédure et évidemment ce sera encore
plus compliqué politiquement à gérer et
un autre élément c'est qu'il y a des
vacances parlementaires la semaine du 20
février
effectivement les débats ne pourraient
pas se prolonger il est inéluctable ce
49-3
il est possible qu'on s'y dirige moi je
j'ai dû alors il y a des arguments
purement juridiques effectivement pour
éviter tous les amendements de passer
par le 49-3 qui évite
d'alourdir le texte et de dans le
magazine et des dispositions qui sont
pas souhaitées par le gouvernement mais
moi j'ai dû beaucoup de mal à croire
qu'il trouve pas une majorité je pense
que là aujourd'hui on est dans une
espèce de comédie de tragies comédie à
la corneille mais qu'on va trouver qui
nous ont trouvé une majorité parce que
je vois assez mal une crise se dégager
de ce de ce texte ça serait une façon
pour ceux qui ne suivent pas le
gouvernement de stérune balle dans le
pied donc avec les républicains avec les
républicains et même à l'intérieur et à
l'intérieur de la majorité ou s'il y a
des brebis galeuses semblent-ils vous
pensez vous aussi Benjamin qu'une
majorité finira par se dégager avec une
partie des députés les républicains
c'est moins évident parce qu'en réalité
chacun aujourd'hui va apporter un petit
peu ses revendications le modem en a
horizon vous avez différentes
composantes de renaissance qui en ont et
LR en a également comment est-ce que
vous arrivez à une version consensuelle
sachant que cette version infinie faut
pas se leurrer il va également y avoir
un peu d'obstruction au Sénat mais il
est assez probable que le texte ne soit
réellement totalement sereinement
examiné quand commission mixte paritaire
c'est à dire en huit clos entre 7
députés et cette sénateurs et que le
texte qui en ressorte soit déjà en
grande partie au conditions de LR aux
conditions du LR au Sénat et que donc
pour trouver ensuite une majorité au
sein de votre Assemblée nationale très
très divisée ça va être encore plus
compliqué donc pour ces raisons là je
crois que le gouvernement est quand même
aujourd'hui au sérieux sérieuse
difficulté il peut y parvenir une fine
et déjà en première lecture pour les
raisons que j'ai données cette
compliquée d'éviter 49 aliné à 3 quant
au vote en lecture définitive et ben là
aussi c'est quand même extrêmement
risqué pour lui parler des députés
républicains mais pas seulement vous le
disiez ivre effectivement il y a aussi
des députés au sein de la majorité qui
se posent des questions est-ce que le
fait qu'Edouard Philippe sont intervenus
pour dire que c'est
comme
indispensablement qui montrent que
effectivement la situation se tend
d'abord vous avez vu que madame la
Première ministre est de plus en plus
présente dans les médias elle arrête pas
alors que pendant
c'était pas un exercice qu'elle
appréciait particulièrement dans ses
interventions elle essaye de faire des
concessions enfin elle a elle a fait
quelques concessions notamment hier dans
le Journal du Dimanche effectivement
vous avez le l'ancien Premier ministre
qui est sorti du bois alors que
on pensait que le texte pour lui était
pas assez musclé et finalement il a dit
qu'il soutenait sans ambiguïté il l'a
dit clairement lors d'une intervention
divisée donc on sent que là il y a la
grosse parlementaire aussi il a dit vous
pouvez le modifier mais attention
le problème de du groupe parlementaire
de Édouard Philippe qui n'est pas député
lui-même c'est qu'à l'intérieur de son
groupe il a quelques enfin dans son
groupe il y a quelques apparentés qui
finalement viennent d'horizons
politiques qui sont pas pas du tout le
sien qui viennent plutôt de sensibilité
de gauche et donc ça c'est pour ça que
je crois qu'il a dans ces rangs 5 ou 6
députés qui sont
pas tellement disposés à tel texte et on
suivra bien sûr l'examen de ce texte on
en parle
[Musique]